today i'm taking my queue from italy
a country that takes home cooking family
and fresh vibrant flavors
extremely seriously the italians are
brilliantly using good food to bring
people together
as well as being delicious today's
dishes are also really quick and easy to
make
leaving you more time to sit down and
enjoy them with your friends and family
fennel sausage frittata
[Music]
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe
because it's basically eggs whatever
else you have left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage
nice hot pan onions in
general from the onions heat nice and
high
season fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages
whole but it's a really nice way of
using them to take them out of their
thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy
fennel sausage into the onions it's
going to release all that flavor
a lot quicker pretty important to keep
that gas
nice and high and the longer you can
rise the sausage
the more flavor you're gonna gain
six whole eggs give your eggs a really
good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in italian
cooking chop it
quite rough some parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
when you fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage gonna make it
even more italian by topping it with
some buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with pans and
cheese get the top
just as tasty as it is the bottom
my frittata needs three and a half to
four minutes under a red hot grill
to achieve the best results always
ensure your oven or grill
are preheated to the perfect temperature
she's ready
this is the thing i love about italian
cooking it's about sharing
but always focusing on the ingredients
look at that
i mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure it comes out
and then spatula underneath and just
leave it it's light fluffy
and it smells incredible and that for me
is a dream come true it's amazing how
far you can take six
eggs and two sausages wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata my
ultimate italian breakfast
it's a cracking start to the day
for my ultimate italian lunch i'm
cooking scrummy sardines
topped with a fragrant gremolata
dressing but first a deliciously fresh
orzo pasta salad this is one of the
hidden delicacies
of italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden
in a soup or broth or minestrone and it
looks like large grains of rice
but once they absorb that water they
double in size
it's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely a pinch of salt
and splash of extra virgin olive oil
fresh bay leaf
into the boiling water and that bay leaf
really helps to flavor the pasta
give it a little pan a turn left and
right that stops any pasta
sticking to the bottom and the secret
behind cooking any pasta is having a
nice gentle
rolling boil you just have the gas up
where the outside of the pan is just
rolling
and all that also is tumbling over each
other gently
boiling pasta rapidly tends to destroy
the outside texture
it doesn't take the marinade or the
vinaigrette or the sauce for the
dressing
parmesan twist of fresh pepper
the zest of the lemon squeeze your lemon
in there
through your fingers to catch all those
seeds bring that together with some
extra virgin olive oil
pine nuts taste delicious toasting them
just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
drain it a little bit of cold water
through it
flows the cooking process down but stops
it from going mushy
it's the size of pumpkin seeds now a
drizzle of olive oil and into the
vinaigrette whilst it's still warm
just above room temperature because the
warmer the pasta the more it absorbs the
vinaigrette
and now some texture rocket not finely
chopped
and the fresh basil as well roll them up
like a big fat cigar
slice in half and then chop the basil
for crunch just sprinkle the toasted
pine nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels glistens
is a delicious very fragrant orzo pasta
salad
now the sardines incredibly healthy and
absolutely delicious grilled
never ever be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish
it's about the condition of the fish
bright eyes
fresh gills nice bright red interior and
the firmness of the flesh
almost you could stand the fish up on
its own it needs to be that fresh
the best way to get flavour into a
sardine is to grill it
light seasoning olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's
a little bit sharp push the rosemary in
almost like you're threading
makes them so much more flavoursome
they'll be scared those fine little
bones
i remember growing up with sardines tin
sardines you didn't turn your nose up at
the bone
once the griddle pan starts to smoke
lightly drizzle
and then sardines on
two and a half to three minutes each
side
now for the gremolata a vinaigrette that
sits beautifully well
on the sardines freshly parsley just run
the knife
once there's nothing worse when you
overchop parsley and all that delicious
flavors let on the board
the zest and juice of an orange and the
lemon
i'm gonna turn them now gremolata is
about fragrance
natural flavors brilliant for grilled
meats as well little touch of salt
and pepper and then olive oil just to
bring it together
the garlic i almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
rate it bring that together
you've got a very fresh clean gremolata
almost if we're sat on the amalfi coast
off and then whilst the sardines are
still
nice and warm and just thinly coat
the gremolata i'd like the path in the
garlic
to sit on top and that's citrus from the
lemon and the orange to sort of dive
underneath
you can see why italian cuisine rides on
the freshest
and the simplest execution they allow
their ingredients
to become the hero not the chef
also salad we're stunning grilled
sardines
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the sea
of the mediterranean delicious
[Music]
we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig jam crostini with
creamy barata
and the heart in maine are beef cheek
ragu with poplar deli
beef cheeks just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah
imagine the size of a cow with them and
the cheek is right underneath here yeah
um i want you to give them a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please
so beet cheeks very cheap i cut that
takes sort of a long time to cook
yeah but give it a bit of love let it
cook in the oven
it comes out like a dream a little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them
really nicely colored shade see it into
the pan
oh cool layer wave
see what that is um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the the beach
beach and then i want the onion chunky
because i'm going to cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down down and then again there
and there so it doesn't overcook so a
really good color
on the cheeks like that so how do you
cook these at our restaurants if they
take so long
they go in the oven literally half past
six seven o'clock in the morning three
and a half four hours to be ready for
lunch
and the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor
the better three nice cloves of garlic
good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your baby
there it is get those onions
and that garlic really nicely colored
put the cheeks back in please right
red wine in cool okay and the red wine
is going to deglaze the pan
so delays will basically sort of rinse
all that flavor off the bottom of the
pan yeah okay because that's going to
make the most amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes
you'll make a much better sauce i'm
going to top that with some stock
so the secret of brazing is having
little of the meat exposed
and 90 percent of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water
turn the gas off and leave the lid
just off at the end there if we had to
cover it completely
the steam hits the top yeah the lid and
all that water comes very important
solar still that's right in the oven 140
150
for about three and a half to four hours
good job
boom we're gonna now do the fig and
broader crostini
oh okay let's take the figs we're gonna
make a nice slightly spicy
fig jam take off the tops yeah in half
and each half into three sugar the touch
of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want to be too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they ah
what's the shape stars star nice
stanley's taken from the hennessy plant
yeah when you dry them like that
so intensifies the flavor really
important to count how we put in there
okay
yeah so one two three four five so
they're just there for a flavor and then
you take them out
that's right secret here let's get that
camera
going so when i hear of jam i don't
think of caramel
no but this is a very fast jam caramel's
starting to color
i want you very carefully to drop the
fig's in there
good so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the caramel
you know what that is well sweet vinegar
i love that on my salad you've got that
sort of
sweet and sour flavor leave that cooking
for three four minutes now let's slice
our chipotle
in italian crostini means little bits of
toast
but it can be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread
we're staying authentically italian with
ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch
of olive oil on there both sides really
important because we're going to grill
the bread
push it down put some lovely
take it off with the chipata toasted we
need to carefully extract the star in
these pods from our piping hot fig jam
my jacket we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light
to crush some of the skin's
disintegrated in that camel
that looks so nice while jack carefully
spreads the crostini with our hot fig
jam
i can unveil the last element to our
starter the creamy italian speciality
burrata a little money bags
they can delicious this looks fun
doesn't it we need to season them
lightly
drizzle over a little olive oil and dust
them with lemon zest
can you imagine that sat there and you
tear some of it off and you stick it on
top of that
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks i've chosen to use
papridelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salting first good olive
oil in
pasta in twist it round
so you don't break it no bring that back
up the ball that's gonna take about
three
or four minutes flat leaf parsley
scrunch it up for me yeah and chop him
now
wait to see these beef cheeks beauties
look at them oh look soft
they're very soft tiny to taste
that's so good oh jack you just dribbled
on your jumper
joke really right drain
the pasta salt pepper
pasta little drizzle
of olive oil i want to put your fresh
pasta
nicely chopped nicely chopped in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little ladle
of the juice put that at the bottom and
you put
the pasta on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
uh what about when you cook this with
your girlfriend one day uh
just tell her where you got the recipe
from william promise promise
i don't want you stealing daddy's
thunder one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
jaws on there and then the third
jaw and then you go over with the sauce
how cool is that delicious you've got
the
porrasa i've got the cheeks
let's go please
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate italian dinner quick thick
jam crostini with creamy borata
a main course of slow cooked beef cheek
ragu with papadely
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best italian
[Music]
tradition
you